how are you tell us about the
inspiration behind the dress and the
beautiful hair
oh it's about
was it the Simplicity but Chic and
modern and that combination and then
just speaking to a little tribute to the
African women I grew up around who were
astounding carrying a great amount of
things on their heads literally and
figuratively and that strength behind it
so that's definitely what where the hair
came from tonight there is lots of
conversation that there is a series in
the works revolving around Okoye what is
happening please tell me that this is
going forward I have been told I can
speak of it vaguely so I will vaguely
respond yes there's my response that's
okay well what can you say about The
Walking Dead
uh yeah well we're shooting uh the Rick
and Michonne
spin-off right now like I got let out of
school early to come here today so
that's happening yeah so what according
would this be set in wakanda would it be
set so I mean she's traveled to the
states we've seen her in different kind
of like what is it set around are we
just are we going to learn more about
who she is and her history and her
background all I'll say is I can answer
none of those questions
however I guess the idea behind a story
like that if one were to exist
would be to explore the character in
ways that we haven't tested yet but who
knows
how prepared are we for what Rihanna is
going to do on that stage tonight
honoring the film honoring Chadwick all
of those yeah that's very special very
special to me very special to all of us
in the wakanda family and we're just
deeply thankful that it this song exists
that she and Tim's and and of course
Ryan and Ludwig came together and
created this beautiful ballad that you
know shows the beauty of our brother and
then she pays tribute to it so the fact
that it's here tonight and it's
nominated
I mean it's everything man what else
matters I don't know what would it mean
for also Angela to win tonight as a
family
and um her she's been such an
inspiration to so many of us for so long
that to me it's just it's just
everything to see her
oh see that happen man you know what I'm
talking about right now it's just
everything and having been on set with
her having had the blessing of working
with this woman see her power her
kindness her ease her Joy of work humor
she's so funny and her generosity and
her work ethic I mean we all know this
has happened a long time ago but the
beauty is she's the first member of the
MCU for the staff and four so she's
creating a precedent that is just so
light so I just couldn't be happier I
mean and I know me too
[Music]